mira pena desesperación o culpabilidad
la crisis climática está perjudicando a
nuestro planeta pero también a nuestra
salud mental un fenómeno que los
investigadores denominan como eco
ansiedad y que según un estudio
publicado en la revista científica the
lancet afecta sobre todo a las
generaciones más jóvenes una encuesta
realizada en 10 países de seis
continentes muestra resultados
alarmantes para los jóvenes de 16 a 25
años de 10.000 jóvenes entrevistados el
75% considera que el futuro es aterrador
y casi el 40% tiene miedo incluso de
tener hijos en concreto la ecociudad es
mayor en los países del hemisferio sur
los jóvenes brasileños filipinos e
indios son los más pesimistas respecto
al futuro del planeta es el activismo
una salida esta duda no la resuelve el
informe pero lo cierto es que las
iniciativas ecologistas de los jóvenes
se han multiplicado en los últimos años
en todo el mundo
es mucho más en todos mis amigos son
ecologistas
un juez y el ministro nos aporta
felicidad en esta difícil situación el
gran triunfo que hay que hablar cueste
lo que cueste y presionar a los
políticos es una buena sensación el
estudio si demuestra una cosa la
inacción del gobierno aumenta la eco
ansiedad entre los jóvenes el 56% de las
personas de entre 16 y 25 años cree que
la humanidad ya está condenada